>>> WE'LL MOVE ON OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THE FACT THAT -- KIDS WAITING
IN THE SCHOOL AND YOU DON'T HAVE
TIME TO ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS?
THIS IS APPALLING.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO TO TAKE
ACTION?
SPEAK TO US!
>> ANGER AND SADNESS OF FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THE SCHOOL SHOOTING
VICTIMS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
THE COMMITTEE RELEASED A DAMNING
77-PAGE REPORT TODAY FINDING
WHAT THEY SAY ARE MULTIPLE
SYSTEMIC FAILURES.
ROSA FLORES WAS THERE.
ARE YOU HEARING THE FAMILY
MEMBERS?
THEY SOUNDED FRUSTRATED.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, THERE'S
SO MUCH OUTRAGE IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
A LOT OF FAMILIES VERY UPSET.
THEY'RE DEMANDING ANSWERS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO ONE OF THE
FATHERS OF A VICTIM ON THE
SIDELINES.
LET ME SET THE SCENE FOR YOU
BECAUSE THE WAY I MET HIM FIRST
IS HAVING A HEATED DISCUSSION
WITH THE MAYOR OF THIS CITY
BECAUSE HE SAID THAT HE WAS
KICKED OUT OF THE PRIVATE
MEETING THAT BOTH LAWMAKERS AND
THE CITY HAD WITH THE VICTIMS'
FAMILIES EARLIER IN THE DAY AND
SO HE WAS ASKING THE MAYOR
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY IF HE'S A
FATHER OF A VICTIM WHY HE WAS
KICKED OUT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I WASN'T A PARENT WHERE LIKE
DAUGHTER THIS IS A BIRTHDAY
CARD.
I HAVE PICTURES WITH MY
DAUGHTER.
TONS OF PICTURES IN MY PHONE.
WHO KICKED ME OUT OF THE
MEETING?
I WAS ESCORTED OUT.
>> I WASN'T IN THERE WHEN YOU
WERE ESCORTED OUT.
>> WHO MADE THE --
>> THERE WAS A LIST THAT WENT
OUT TO THE FAMILIES AND COMING
THAT MEETING TODAY.
I DON'T HAVE THAT LIST.
>> OKAY.
>> WHAT I TOLD THEM IS I WOULD
FACILITATE THE LEGISLATURE
COMING TO SPEAK TO THE FAMILIES.
THEY HELPED ME TOUCH THE
FAMILIES.
>> I'M THE FATHER OF ONE OF THE
KIDS AND YOU WEREN'T ON THE
LIST.
>> THE DEAN.
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> I MEAN, WE MEANT NO DISN'T
RESPECT BUT I DIDN'T MAKE THE
LIST.
>> WHO DID?
>> THEY MADE THE LIST.
>> HECTOR GONZALEZ.
>> THERE WAS A MEETING AT THE
COLLEGE AT 2:00 AND THAT WAS FOR
THE FAMILIES TO -- IT WAS LIKE A
REVIEW OF THE INVESTIGATION FOR
THE FAMILIES DIRECTLY SO I WENT
TO GO SIT INSIDE AND ASKED TO
LEAVE BECAUSE I WASN'T ON THE
LIST BUT MY DAUGHTER PASSED
AWAY.
YOU KNOW?
>> CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT YOUR
DAUGHTER?
>> SHE WAS JUST AN AWESOME
PERSON.
THE LIGHT OF MY LIFE.
SHE WAS LIKE ME.
WE HAD A SPECIAL BOND.
YOU KNOW?
IT'S ALL BEEN HARD.
RIGHT?
AND THEN SOMEBODY TELLING ME YOU
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HERE.
I HAVE A DOCUMENT THAT SAYS THAT
I PAID MY FINANCIAL DUTIES,
VISITED WITH MY CHILD.
THE BIRTH FATHER.
I DON'T HAVE THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE BUT I CAN GET THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A STATE
WHERE SOMETIMES MOMS GET THE
UPPER HAND AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
LOSE SIGHT OF THAT.
THEY ONLY LISTEN TO ONE SIDE OF
THE STORY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Reporter: NOW, RYAN, THE
QUESTION I ASKED HIM AFTER IS
WHAT EMOTIONS WERE GOING THROUGH
HIM AS HE WAS GOING THROUGH THAT
EARLIER IN THE DAY AND KICKED
OUT OF A MEETING WHERE HE
LET'S BREAK THIS DOWN NOW.
CHIEF, THIS IS JUST SOME OF THE
WAYS THE LEGISLATORS DESCRIBED
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE.
MULTIPLE SYSTEMIC FAILURES.
L
LACKADAISICAL.
NEARLY 400 LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS DESCEND ON AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER SITUATION.
HOW CAN YOU EXPLAIN THIS?
>> YOU CAN'T EXPLAIN IT.
IT WAS A TOTAL FAILURE AT A LOT
OF DIFFERENT LEVELS.
JUST THE FACT OF 300 OR 400
POLICE OFFICERS AT A SCENE,
THAT'S A PROBLEM IN AND OF
ITSELF.
YOU CAN HAVE TOO MANY PEOPLE
RESPOND.
YOU NEED THE PEOPLE WITH
SPECIFIC ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES SO WHEN YOU SET
UP INCIDENT COMMAND YOU DEAL
WITH WHAT'S GOING ON INSIDE THE
BUILDING AND CONTROL WHAT'S
HAPPENING OUTSIDE.
CLEARLY THERE WAS NO LEADERSHIP
AT ALL.
NO INCIDENT COMMAND SET UP OR
UNIFIED COMMAND.
YOU HAD A VARIETY OF AGENCIES
RESPONDING.
APPARENTLY NOBODY KNEW WHAT WAS
EXPECTED OF THEM.
WHAT TO DO.
NO TACTICAL PLANNING TO MAKE
ENTRY INTO THAT CLASSROOM UNTIL
AFTER 70-SOME ODD MINUTES
PASSED.
ONE THING AFTER THE OTHER ALL
BAD.
>> AMY, IN THE PRESS CONFERENCE
WE HEARD A TEXAS STATE LAWMAKERS
SAY THAT ROBB ELEMENTARY WAS NOT
PREPARED.
WHAT SECURITY LAPSES STOOD OUT?
>> I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IT IS NOT JUST TO
WRITE DOWN A POLICY THAT SAYS WE
LOCK THIS DOOR.
YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE TRAINED AND
UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE AND THE
IMPORTANCE.
THAT WE HOLE THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
NUMBER ONE MISSION IS TO KEEP
KIDS SAFE.
YOU CAN'T WRITE IT DOWN AND SAY
THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH.
FOR ANY OF THE MYRIAD THREATS
THAT SCHOOLS FACE.
IT NEEDS TO GO FAR BEYOND
TALKING ABOUT ABOUTIVE SHOOTER
BUT WHAT ABOUT SCHOOL EVERY DAY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENT OR
NOT?
>> SHOULD THIS BE A WAKE-UP CALL
FOR SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE THINK IT WON'T HAPPEN IN MY
BACKYARD BUT ANY OF US COULD BE
VULNERABLE TO THIS.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR
ADMINISTRATORS AS WE PREPARE TO
GO BACK TO SCHOOL TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DOOR IS LOCKED
PROPERLY?
>> THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
I THINK THE PROBLEM IS WE FIXATE
ON AN ACTIVE SCHOOL SHOOTING.
WE SEE THE RESPONSES.
BUT EVERY SCHOOL FACES A CRISIS
EVENT, WHETHER IT'S A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY OR A NONCUSTODIAL
PARENT.
IF WE DON'T PROVIDE THEM WITH
TRAINING AND RESOURCES YOU LIVE
THE NIGHTMARES OVER AND OVER
UNTIL YOU TRAIN THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FACED WITH THE INCIDENTS
FIRST.
THEY ARE THE FIST FIRST
RESPONDERS.
>> THEY COULDN'T ANSWER IF THE
DOOR WAS LOCKED.
NOBODY TRIED THE HANDLE.
SHOULDN'T THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO GET INTO THE ROOM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
TRAINING.
SINCE COLUMBINE AND VIRGINIA
TECH TRAINING CHANGED.
USED TO BE CONTAIN.
WAIT FOR S.W.A.T.
NOW FIRST OFFICERS ON THE SCENE
YOU GO TO THE SOUND OF THE
GUNSHOTS.
THE FIRST OFFICER THAT IS
ARRIVED DID THAT.
THEY WENT TO THE DOOR.
THEY WENT TOWARD THE GUN FIRE
BUT GETTING FIRED UPON THEY
RETREATED WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT RATHER THAN
REGROUP WITH THE OFFICERS TO GO
BACK DOWN WITH A TACTICAL PLAN
NOBODY DID ANYTHING FOR 70
MINUTES OR SO.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A TACTICAL PLAN
PUT TOGETHER TO DO IT QUICKLY.
CREATE A DIVERSION.
FIND A WAY TO GET INTO THE
CLASSROOM.
WHETHER IT'S A DOOR UNLOCKED,
YOU HAVE TO USE A TOOL TO PRY
THE DOOR OPEN.
WHATEVER IT IS YOU HAVE TO DO.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE INJURED,
BLEEDING AND GOT TO GET TO
MEDICAL ATTENTION AND YOU HAVE
TO DO WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
>> THE TEXAS OFFICIALS TOOK THE
OFFICERS TO TASK.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
>> THE OFFICERS WHO KNEW OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THIS WAS
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATION
SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE.
WE ARE VERY CLEAR ON THAT.
>> THE REPORT SAYS IF YOU ARE
NOT WILLING TO PUT THE LIVES OF
THE PEOPLE YOU SERVE, THE
CHILDREN, BEFORE YOUR OWN, IN MY
VIEW YOU SHOULD FIND ANOTHER
JOB.
>> THERE HAVEN'T BEEN TOO MANY
OFFICERS TAKEN TO TASK.
THE ACTING CHIEF IS PLACED ON
LEAVE.
DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE SUSPENSIONS
OR FIRINGS AS THE INVESTIGATION
GOES FORWARD?
>> I DO AND I THINK THERE SHOULD
BE.
LISTEN.
YOU KNOW.
WHEN YOU BECOME A POLICE OFFICER
YOU ALIZE THAT YOU MAY BE CALLED
UPON TO PUT YOUR OWN LIFE AT
RISK TO PROTECT OTHERS.
THAT'S PART OF THE JOB.
HOPEFULLY THAT SITUATION NEVER
COMES UP BUT YOU HAVE TO STEP
UP.
IF YOU CAN'T DO THAT THEN YOU
HAVE CHOSEN THE WRONG PROFESSION
TO BE IN.
I HAVE BEEN IN SHOOTINGS AND
FIRED UPON.
IT IS NOT A GOOD FEELING.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT YOURSELF AND
OTHERS.
THEY FAILED TO DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY LIVE WITH
THEMSELVES IN THAT HALLWAY
WITHOUT TAKING ACTION KNOWING
THAT MANY OF THE PEOPLE PROBABLY
BLED TO DEATH STANDING AROUND.
NO.
SOMETHING'S GOT TO HAPPEN.